THIS, BETTER THAN THIS THAN
BUYING INTO HALF THE CRAP
THEY'RE BUYING INTO.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
SPREADING IT.
FOX HOSTS AREN'T THE ONLY PEOPLE
GIVING ANTI-CONSPIRACY THEORY
PLATFORMS.
THEY'RE GETTING HELP FROM ONE
UNITED STATES SENATOR AND THAT
IS RON JOHNSON, REPUBLICAN FROM
WISCONSIN.
HE'S ON THE RADIO TALK ABOUT IT.
LIKE FOX'S ANTI-CHIEF SCIENCE
OFFICERS JOHNSON PUSHES THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY LIKE, WHAT,
I'M JUST ASKING THE QUESTION.
THE FIRST CLAIM, JOHNSON SAYS
THOUSANDS OF DEATHS ARE FROM
VACCINES.
>> I CAN REPORT WHAT'S BEING
REPORTED ON THE VERAS SYSTEM.
ADVERSE AFFECT REPORTING SYSTEM,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S AN EM PERFECT SYSTEM.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THIS WITH A
GRAIN OF SALT, BUT ACCORDING TO
THE VAERS SRJS WE'RE OVER 3,000
DEATHS AFTER TAKING THE VACCINE.
>> TRULY, MADLY, DEEPLY FALSE.
THE SYSTEM WHICH HE REFERS TO IS
NOT AN OFFICIAL VETTED REPORT.
ANYONE CAN SUBMIT A REPORT.
THE SYSTEM'S WEBSITE SAYS IT
CONTAINS INFORMATION THAT IS,
QUOTE, INCOMPLETE, INACCURATE,
CO-INDENTAL, OR UNVERIFIABLE.
THE SYSTEM'S PURPOSE IS FOR THE
CDC TO MONITOR ADVERSE EFFECTS
AND FOLLOW UP ON INVESTIGATIONS.
IT'S LIKE A TIP LINE.
WHEN CNN ASKED JOHNSON FOR A
COMMENT, A SPOKESPERSON SAID
JOHNSON IS CALLING FOR
SUBMISSIONS TO THE SYSTEM, THAT
THEY BE, QUOTE, TAKEN SERIOUSLY
AND RESEARCH WHAT IS GOING ON.
BUT, I MEAN IS THAT REALLY HIS
POINT BECAUSE THEY, THIS TIP
LINE, THEY'RE ALREADY DOING.
THAT SINCE LAST YEAR, OVER 2
MILLION DOSES HAVE BEEN GIVEN
AND THEY RECEIVED 4,100 REPORTS
OF DEATHS OF PEOPLE WHO GOT THE
VACCINE.
THAT'S 0.00147%.
A REVIEW INCLUDING DEALT
CERTIFICATES, AUTOPSY, AND
MEDICAL EXPERTS HAVE NOT.
OF THOSE 4,100, THERE'S NO
PROVEN LINK THEY DIED BECAUSE OF
A COVID VACCINE.
>> SO JON'S SECOND UNSCIENTIFIC
CLAIM THAT THERE'S A RISK FOR
PEOPLE WHO GET THE VACCINE WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY INFECTED WITH
COVID, KEEP IN MIND HE WAS
INFECTED LAST YEAR.
>> PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY HAD COVID
BECAUSE YOU DIE NOT OF COVID.
YOU DIE OF THE IMMUNE SYSTEM --
THE OVERREACTION TO COVID.
SO THERE'S A CONCERN THERE.
>> COMPLETELY UTTERLY
FANTASTICALLY WRONG.
THE CONVENIENCE ARE SAFE AND
RECOMMENDED FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY HAD COVID.
THE CDC RECOMMENDS YOU GET
VACCINATED EVEN IF YOU HAVE HAD
IT BECAUSE, QUOTE, EXPERTS DO
NOT KNOW HOW LONG YOU ARE
PROTECTED FROM GETTING SICK,
AGAIN, AFTER RECOVERING FROM
COVID.
DOCTORS WERE SPOKEN TO ABOUT
THIS.
ONE DOCTOR SAID, SHOCK, HE IS
NOT AWARE OF ANY DATA TO SUPPORT
SENATOR JON'S ALLEGATION.
ANOTHER SAID EVEN IF YOU HAVE
BEEN INFECTED, THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE YOU DEVELOP AN
IMMUNITY FROM IT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THOSE WHO LISTEN TO RON JOHNSON
SPEW THIS ON THE RADIO LIKELY OR
WON'T HEAR THIS.
INSTEAD THEY'LL BELIEVE IT AS
FACT AND REFUSE TO GET A
CONVENIENCE FOR FALSE REASONS.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THAT'S WHAT CONCERNS ME.
THAT'S WHERE I START ASKING A
LOT MORE QUESTIONS.
WHEN THINGS DON'T MAKE SENSE TO
ME, I ASK QUESTIONS.
>> RON JOHNSON ZBRAD YATED WITH
A DEGREE IN ACCOUNTING.
HE'S NOT A DOCTOR.
HE'S NOT A SCIENTIST.
>> AND HE DOESN'T LISTEN TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
HOSPITALIZATIONS, DEATHS, CASES,
THEY'RE DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY
ACROSS THE U.S.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE OF THE H HERD
IMMUNITY.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
GONE INTO LOCKDOWN.
IT'S HALF OF THE U.S. POPULATION